ووصف الرئيس الاوكراني الاجتماع الذي
ستشهده مدينه جده السعوديه بشان اوكرانيا
بالمهم للغايه قال ايضا عشيه الاجتماع ان
مصير الملايين في افريقيا واسيا ومناطق
اخرى يتوقف على مدى سرعه تنفيذ معادله
السلام بحسب تعبيره
سيبدا في جده اجتماع لمستشرير رؤساء الدول
وممثلي وزاره الخارجيه بشان صيغه السلام
سيتم تمثيل العديد من البلدان بما في ذلك
دول الجنوب العالمي هذا مهم للغايه لانه
في مسائل مثل الامن الغذائي يعتمد مصير
ملايين الاشخاص في افريقيا واسيا واجزاء
اخرى من العالم بشكل مباشر على مدى سرعه
العالم في تنفيذ معادله السلام انا ممتن
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه على هذه المنصه
للمفاوضات
الدوليه بجامعه في النرويج والخبير في
السعوديه الروسيه مرحبا دكتور في خدمتنا
الاخباريه هذا اليوم من الجزيره
فعليا منذ بدايه هذه الازمه كانت هناك
الكثير من المبادرات الدبلوماسيه لح هذه
هي الازمه
الان بعد ساعات هناك قمه جده في تقديرك ما
الذي يجب ان تركز عليه هذه القمه
لاحدث اختراقا في هذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
في انهاء هذه الحرب لن اسمى هذه القمه هي
قمه السلام السبب في ذلك هو ان روسيا لم
تتم دعوتها وبالتالي فان هذا الامر لن
يؤدي الى عمليه التفاوض او الى قمه من اجل
الزمان سلام عفوا اذا هذه القمه ستركز على
خطه السلام وبالتالي هناك محاوله من قبل
اوكرانيا لاسترجاع شبه جزيره القرم
والحصول على تعويضات من قبل روسيا
وان تتخلى روسيا عن بعض
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها اذا هي بمثابه
استسلام بالنسبه لروسي هذا جهد من قبل
النوتو من اجل الفوزي
العمل الذي يتم من خلال هذا التحالف لن
نسمي هذه القمه هي قمه سلام لا اعتقد انها
ستحقق اي شيء لان الهدف الذي تحتاج ان
تقوم به او ترمي للقيام به هو الفوز لا
ارى اي سلام قد يتمخض عن هذه العمليه في
ضوء ايضا التحركات الدبلوماسيه وبالتوازي
معها ايضا هناك تطورات على المستوى
الميداني على الارض الاوكرانيون يتحدثون
في هذه المرحله عن نجاحهم في نقل المعركه
الى الداخل الروسي في تقديركم وبمعرفتكم
بشان الروسي ماذا تتوقعون فيما يتعلق
بالرد رد الفعل الروسي على نقل الهجوم
بالمسيرات ان كانت طائرات او او زوارق الى
داخل الروسي
اذا هذا تصعيد وهذا يعني ان روسيا ستقوم
بالرد بصرامه اكبر ضد الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لكن المشكله هي اكثر سوءا مما حدث لماذا
لان اوكرانيا استهدفت روسيا من خلال عدد
من المناطق نتحدث هنا عن خليج نيفرسيسك
وهي تستخدم اسلحه نيتو لاستهداف اراضي
روسيه عمليه الاستهداف تعتمد على معلومات
استخباراتيه تعود الى النيتو لان هذه
الحرب هي حرب بالوكاله ما بين النيتو
وروسيا وهذا يوسع نطاق هذه الحرب يتضمن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كذلك الهدف
كما تمت الاشاره الى ذلك من قبل
الامريكيين
والبريطانيين هم ان يريدون ان يضعف
اسست العسكريه الروسيه ان يكون هناك تغيير
للنظام وانهيار للمنظومه ككل هذه العمليه
هي عمليه تصعيد كبيره ماذا ستكون رده
الفعل اذا روسيا هي في معضله اذا لم تستجب
لعمليه التصعيد هاته فهذا سيعزز زيتول
يصبح اكثر عدوانيه ضد روسيا شكرا لك
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه